coming from yourself when prices just
like that my earnings are gonna come
that I invest in property before to get
into it in return
big farms what's today's fantastic I
really enjoy especially about the
property option and the rent to rent and
indeed today's been amazing
the biggest thing today was conferred
Tiffany's member sechina market their
actual market roof I moved corner agents
really enjoyed the light deals basically
and actually knowing how to calculate
and you return on investment was very
grateful equation what we do here is yes
we learn let's go through this but then
we actually do it so this maxi they make
you calls get their laptops out finding
deals and they're currently working
through the formulas to see if it's
worth buying
the excellent excellent course wonderful
nature theory and practical practical
application of lessons learned really
enjoyed it
I recommend everyone calm down because
their practical experience training it's
really worthwhile
that's very good my finger brush
apartment fantastic energy possess
information real game champ in terms of
mindset thank you
the course is very very well presented
and I particularly found useful these
options which gave me actually discuss
was much better than the over course I
already be comparing to one I was last
year was three days course and three
four days and I got might be a half of a
knowledge comparing to what I got today
from just like eight hours with Samuel
this course 21 action thank you
I came here this morning not really
knowing where I'm going this property
investment idea you know having be on
the course now I feel I'm ready to go so
when you are getting property tomorrow